Square.
Hello,
I'm Dana.
Welcome to this intelligence squared
debate.
It's coming to you from Cadogan Hall in
central London.
It's exactly 10 years ago that nine 11
happened.
Nearly 3000 people were killed in those
attacks in America and they changed the
course of world history forever.
George W.
Bush launched his war on terror in a
matter of weeks.
Afghanistan was invaded in order to
remove the Taliban from power who had
harbored al-Qaida.
And then in March,
2003 there was the controversial war in
Iraq.
The Americans set up Guantanamo Bay as a
detention center to interrogate
terrorist suspects.
The motion in our debate a decade on was
the war on terror,
the right response to nine 11 and in our
panel we have some of the key figures
from that time purveyors,
Musharraf was president of parking
stones.
He is arguing for the motion along with
colleen graffy,
who served in the Bush administration.
Awesome.
Arguing against the motions.
So Jeremy Green Stalk,
who was the senior British diplomat at
the time
and,
and the influential French politician
doctor about not [inaudible].
Welcome.
Good luck to you all.
Now before we hear you,
um,
make your opening statement,
it's nice.
You just very quickly run through what
to expect in our debate.
As you,
our audience were coming in,
you were almost to vote to see where you
stand on the motion right now.
Then each of our panel members will make
their opening statements to you.
Then you will have a chance to put
questions or even make comments indeed
to our panel members.
After that,
they will make some brief closing
arguments and we will ask you to vote
again to see if you've perhaps changed
your mind and where the boat that
stands.
So I hope that's all clear.